[Applause]
happy monday everyone so the rittenhouse
trial might have lasted a few weeks but
like brian stelter's hair the fallout
was immediate
which is good for shows like mine
because i can just press cruise control
and let the morons speak for themselves
seriously this script could have been
written by the producers of full house
only the show would have been called
fuller
kyle rittenhouse was just 17 years old
when he drove across state lines he's
driving across state lines he crosses
the state line he crosses the state line
across state lines who cross state lines
came across state lines this guy came
over state lines provocatively drove
across state lines
gee it almost makes you wonder that they
want you to think he drove across faint
lines
i had no idea
but it's amazing one simple fact can be
distorted and no producer has taken the
time to correct it they're too busy
trying to adjust the meds for joy reid
and spotting chris cuomo on his bench
meanwhile eric swalwell didn't drive
across state lines but what did the
fabricating fart bag do with state
secrets
when he did the bang bang with the fang
fang
that whole story stinks to high heaven
partly because swalwell just had cabbage
for dinner
all right i'll stop but of course kyle
rittenhouse did not did not take a gun
across state lines you think a party
that has a reputation of stealing
elections would know where state lines
are drawn but good liars know that
correcting a lie makes people stop
trusting you and the lies now come from
everywhere
here's the thing
the black lives matter protest
was actually taking place
because jacob blake was shot and killed
by police officers
uh no that didn't happen
but there's nobody better to go to for
honest news than a former point guard
from the nba
that's like you asking me how to dunk a
basketball
but if you spout political nonsense like
that you might get banned on twitter and
facebook but here they get a shoe
contract from nike all sorts of vacuous
celebs were weighing in with naive
tweets it's great here's rhys
witherspoon repeating the same
inaccuracies
they all love a good script whether it's
from a writer or a pharmacist
you have politicians like capital fat
pants gerald nodler
calling on the doj to review the verdict
walking corpse bill de blasio fans the
flames of his own city with a criminally
insane tweet
but i guess when folks are worse off
under your policies sowing racial
division is the best distraction then
there's the hypothetical question what
if ridden house were black
you know you're gonna have people saying
if he was black this would be different
right because we're dealing with
systemic injustice right now he has a
privilege of whiteness please understand
that if kyle rittenhouse was black
today's outcome would have been
different if a black person had got an
ar-15 and went to
a city
where someone was being harmed if we'd
gone to brunswick georgia with ar-15 and
say i'm here to protect all young black
joggers and end up killing two people we
would have gone to jail
so their best argument that ridden house
should have been convicted is
speculation about a hypothetical event
that didn't happen their implication
those who defend a white ridden house
wouldn't defend a black version of
ridden house it's mind-reading but above
all it's stupid a black man andrew
coffey iv was acquitted of attempted
murder charges last week after 12 jurors
found he had reason to believe he was
being attacked during a swat team raid
and there is no mass outrage from
conservatives over that because as long
as you view this through the prism of
self-defense there is no racial angle
with kyle all the attackers were white
and i'm thinking actual white
supremacists rarely support an
unjustified shooting of white people
and if rittenhouse were black those
defending rittenhouse would not only
defend him they might elect him to
office
but the people who bring up the
so-called black written house would
smear him if he indeed existed black
rittenhouse would now be the face of
white supremacy just like larry elder
who is black remember a white person in
a gorilla mask attacked him and the
media barely noticed there was
condoleezza rice and then winsome sears
who posed with a gun and is black but is
a white supremacist for being elected as
a republican nothing says you have a
grip on the race issue like calling
black people white
they're as confused as a guy in assless
leather chaps at a sports bar
what
was i embarrassed
the bars have the same names but what
but that's what happens when you rely on
one prism to look at life race it takes
all the real thinking off the table i
mean if kyle written house we're black
it wouldn't be you who disowned him it
would be the left because they're
operating solely on lines of race and
race must adhere to a specific ideal
ideology and so the meltdowns get worse
i find these people disgusting ellie i'm
disgusted at what i'm seeing it's not
just this trial it's other trials but
this in particular the fact that white
supremacists roam the halls of congress
freely and celebrate this little
murderous white supremacist this country
was built on the idea
of that white men had a a a particular
kind of freedom and a particular kind of
citizenship that only they have
that gives you know from the slave
catchers on the right to inflict
violence there is a paw of
permissiveness towards white violence
i'd send a social worker to check on all
these people but maybe medicine is
racist too
of course cnn reports there's nothing
more frightening in america than an
angry white man the writer a racist
states quote a vision of white
masculinity allows some white men to
feel as if they can rule and brutalize
without consequence so does that vision
include the white guys who are trying to
kill ridden house i doubt that but if
that's true why do they still have white
men working and running cnn shouldn't
they step down those racists meanwhile
the virginia university chemistry
department says the ridden house
acquittal hampers the progress of
science
i guess it could if someone tries to
defend themselves from attackers with a
bunsen burner
but the p but the people who written i
was killed in self-defense how did that
hurt science were they trying to split
heads or split atoms
the university of massachusetts hosted
segregated processing spaces after the
verdict because to solve their
deliberate racial division
they want more racial division it's not
just for their admission standards
anymore you see how one filter creates
this idiocy race how long before we see
a math problem on a test that asks how
many times do 10 white supremacists go
into 50 black peaceful protests
and it can never be done in reverse i
wonder what the angry white male has to
say
[Music]
oh hey sorry
didn't hear the question i've had these
earplugs in my ears for three days so i
wouldn't lose my sanity
these babies work
but how does the angry black male feel
[Music]
sir as you know these are very serious
crimes we have fingerprint evidence we
have motive everything we need to place
you at the scene of the crime
the white supremacists did it
no no no the victim was beaten with a
championship belt we have it on camera
a champion white supremacist kid
okay no i don't know how to put this
lightly but your dna was found
everywhere
el blanco supremicisto
[Applause]
[Music]
bilingual
so we know why this is happening we see
how life works effectively through
filters on incentives reciprocity
responsibility self-defense and family
like a good wedding photographer or a
good porn director we can view every
issue from different angles
but if all you see is race then you
can't see anything else coming all you
see is just what's fuming in your
narrative corrupted brain which is why
msnbc and others are melting like a
popsicle being eaten in a tanning bed
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else